recently a new law went into effect in
south carolina that banned most
abortions
one day later the law was suspended but
similar laws have been passed in more
than 10 states
now i know we're all liberal as hell
around these parts but
i got a confession to make i like that
law
i freaking love it when a man tells me
what to do
oh yeah hell yeah i guess you could say
i'm a little freak i want you to
tell me what to do with my body baby
be a man and make me a plan for
something that has nothing to do with
[Music]
you
what about my sexy shade wear big loose
blouse cause i don't want to be aroused
how much money should i make not enough
for
rent of what i make like 80 percent
every woman needs a man oh yes it's true
how else would you know what to do
i want you to tell me what to do
with my body baby
hey you're not a doctor so that means
you want to spend your time telling me
what to do
do it like this
[Music]
like this
all right baby give it all to me
i'm so tired of bodily autonomy
i'm into submission and i want your
permission so may i know you didn't
really hear me out
i'm saying can i no
oh so should we go back to the chorus or
what do you want to do because we could
just quiet
don't even want you to be singing this
song
i should have sung it by myself all
along
cause i wanna tell you what to do
with your body baby
don't need that i'm the man so i
make the plan i got it i'm sorry about
[Music]
turkey
[Music]
[Applause]
you